overwhelmingly Millennials are in favor
of socialism or at least they have a
very positive view of socialism
Millennials don't know who people like
Pol Pot or Stalin or Mao are which is
kind of to me what being a millennial is
all about like all of the enthusiasm
with none of the knowledge hey hey and
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sunday special we have Lauren Chen from
the blaze TV joining us we'll get to her
in just one second but first I know this
is a really awkward thing to talk about
but sex particularly within marriage is
one of the crucial aspects of a healthy
life and like any other aspect of your
health sometimes things don't work the
way they're supposed to that's not
something to be ashamed about it's
something to get fixed and that's where
our friends at Roman come in studies
show that 70 percent of dudes who
experience erectile dysfunction don't
get treated for it thankfully Roman
created an easy way to get checked out
by a doctor and get treated for IDI
online Roman is a one stop shop where
licensed US physicians can diagnose easy
and SCHIP medication directly to your
door with Roman there are no waiting
rooms or awkward face to face
conversations or uncomfortable trips to
the pharmacy he can handle everything
discreetly online all you have to do is
visit get Roman comm slash pen and
complete a dynamic online visit chat
with a doctor get genuine medication
delivered to your door in discreet
unmarked packaging dudes just go online
get checked by the doctor erectile
dysfunction is a problem that guys don't
tend to tackle both Roman it's pretty
simple so go take care of it right now
for a free online visit go to get Roman
comm slash Ben that's get Roman comm
slash Ben for a free online visit once
more get Roman comm slash Ben don't let
the problem wait get Roman comm slash
Ben Lauren thanks so much for stopping
by thank you so much for having me so
let's just jump right in with a little
bit of your background for folks who
don't know your work or how you became a
host on blaze TV take me from what you
wore which was sort of a YouTube host to
being on blaze TV and having a large
following in all of this sure well I
started my youtube channel it's gonna be
three years ago in May and I was just
uploading videos you know once or twice
a month just for fun there were little
dinky slideshow presentations that I did
about social issues and it went on the
minimum wage and it was really just a
side hobby but eventually I started to
get more subscribers and more popular
and kind of got enough of a following
where I could make that my full-time job
and then last year I ended up starting a
show with Sierra
which is now the blaze TV and so yeah
right now we do three episodes a week
everything's on YouTube for people to
see if they want to subscribe to Lauren
Chen and yeah we we kind of talk about
cultural issues more so than political
ones right now just because I feel like
as someone who is a millennial and who's
trying to reach out to people around my
age the cultural issues are really where
most of the focus is when we're talking
about what affects people in their day
to day lives on social media in their
college classes though the films and
stuff they have to deal with so you know
you're a genuine millennial I'm like at
the very tail end of the Millennials I
get to technically slide in right under
the wire millennial millennial how old
are you I am 24 okay it's still okay to
ask me that I'm young enough where it's
right it's not insulting yeah I knew
that it wasn't insulting so I could ask
you that so how did you become
conservative at age 24 so growing up I
was my family was pretty apolitical I
mean we didn't really talk about
politics we I grew up in Asia so the
politics wouldn't been the same anyway
but we didn't really talk about anything
to do with like taxes or anything like
that but just socially I came from a
family maybe it's you know the Asian dad
influence that I have that was just very
pro-family Pro hard work Pro individual
responsibility so I think socially I was
always kind of naturally conservative
and then when I started to get into
politics just on my own I feel like
those values just natural add themselves
to me being you know pro individual
liberty and freedom ie conservative so I
mean when I started college at 17 I was
in the College Republicans at USC one of
us I think like 35 of us out of a campus
of 60,000 so yeah I never really had a
moment where I was liberal and then
changed which I think is maybe rare for
people who are my age and I think a lot
of that just had to do with you know my
family's outlook on things rather than I
don't like to think that I'm brainwashed
but I was just raised with a certain set
of values that I think when translated
into government do favor conservatism
over liberalism so I'm gonna ask you a
version of a question that I get all the
time I get quite asked all the time
because I'm Jewish why do so many Jews
vote for the left I'm gonna ask you why
do so many folks who are Asian vote for
Democrats considering that it is a lot
of Democratic policies that seems to be
cutting against the interest of a lot of
Asian folks who are the number one
earning by household group in the United
States who are systematically
disadvantaged
campuses by affirmative action programs
disproportionately why do you think
that's happening I think it's happening
because the left has very very I mean
intelligently crafted a narrative where
people say that Republicans and
conservatives are racist they hate
immigrants they hate Asian people so it
only makes sense to vote for Democrats
which is frustrating because if you
actually talk to I mean people in the
Asian community I mean they're Pro small
business so many Asian immigrants owned
small businesses themselves you know
socially they're also conservative
there's not really much in the
Democratic platform that appeals to
Asian people on math aside from the idea
that conservatives are racist and hate
them for their skin color which is
obviously false so I mean it's I I like
to try and bring up as much as possible
how like you said Democrats and
progressives they really aren't for
Asians because Asians are I mean if
we're looking at the oppression
hierarchy doing even better than white
people so we see I mean time and time
again when it comes to things like
affirmative action they're happy to
throw Asians under the bus for the
interests of like other more special
minority groups it's actually it's
really frustrating me that so many
Asians are I don't know falling for it
so you have a multi-ethnic background
you didn't in a lot of countries other
than the United States has that shaped
your view of both the United States
generally and then race in the United
States you in contrasting you've lived
in Canada you've lived obviously in Asia
how does that shape your view of the
United States and then on sort of the
the racial polarization scale where do
you think the u.s. is right now well I
mean economically the way living in Asia
shaped my point of view I mean I I've
lived in San poor and Shanghai and Hong
Kong obviously very economically
prosperous country places and cities but
I've also visited places like Thailand
Indonesia which are developing countries
so my background what it means to me is
that I understand what actual poverty
looks like not you know millennial I
have college loans therefore I think
capitalism is broken tight poverty so I
think that perspective has been really
important to me because I mean you hear
a lot of Democrats were essentially
socialists now disparaging capitalism
and saying that you know the American
Dream is dead I mean if you look at
other countries the u.s. is doing
extraordinarily well there's no denying
that so I think that perspective has
been important and in terms of race
relations it's funny
you know growing up obviously I've been
mixed race the entire time there's never
time where I was not mixed race it's
just been part of my reality it was
never something that I really thought
about I never thought it was strange it
was just like yeah my mom's white and
Canadian my dad's Chinese it is what it
is I'm both the first time I was really
confronted with I don't know the
American interpretation of race was when
I found myself an American campus and I
realized how although the u.s. is
absolutely one of the least racist
racist places I've ever been and I think
you know when they do studies about
approval rates for things like
interracial marriages it's consistently
one of the least racist places in the
world that's there's no denying that but
it just is also one of the places that's
most obsessed with race which is really
really strange to me you know for the
amount of actual racists there are in
the United States
ie very few it seems like we're talking
about race a disproportionate amount so
he before you were sort of the
pseudo-intellectual that's named your
show over at blaze TV you're roaming
millennial so your brand is very tied in
to the Millennials well what is it the
Millennials are not getting about
American politics that so many of them
are trending towards socialism and and
radicalism and intersectionality well
it's funny because if you we've done
videos about this if you look at polls
overwhelmingly Millennials are in favor
of socialism or at least they have a
very positive view of socialism but if
you actually probe them a little bit
deeper most or at least a good number of
Millennials don't know who people like
Pol Pot or Stalin or Mao are so it's
funny because like we're very very warm
toward socialism as an ideology but at
the same time we don't know anything
about socialism as an ideology which is
kind of to me what being a millennial is
all about like all of the enthusiasm
with none of the knowledge so I think if
we kind of try to break down millennial
politics it's it's all about trying to
do what feels good and what seems fair
and righteous but that's not necessarily
backed up in history and economic fact
and I think ultimately it's a failure of
Education Millennials don't know enough
about this the world and the system that
they're soon gonna be in charge of
running and that's scary what do you
think is the best way for conservatives
to reach out so obviously we're both
speaking to a young audience
disproportionately
audience my feeling has been that a lot
of conservative leaders have not
actually done the hard work of talking
about ideas it's been a lot of sort of
follow the leader where do you think
conservatives can do better where is
their upside for conservatives in
talking to young people well I think if
we look at Gen Z right now they are more
conservative than any generation has
been in a long time and I think we
really need to capitalize on that but I
don't think we can win the battle of
ideas without engaging in culture more
than we have in the past I mean people
like you are doing a great job because
without conservative commentators you
have to understand the average
millennial the the school that they go
to it's preaching progressivism the
media that they watch the the films and
TV series that they watch it's all
enforcing this one idea so unless we
have any any media of our own to kind of
counter it then it's just natural that
these people are gonna end up believing
what everyone else around them is saying
which is that you know the u.s. is an
oppressor capitalism is evil socialism
is what's fair etcetera etc in the
future I think if we actually want
things to be a bit more balanced in
terms of what children are learning
growing up and I'm not saying that we
need to counteract liberal brainwashing
with conservative brainwashing but we do
need to try and make school more about
learning ideas and critical thinking
rather than just feeding them
regurgitate regurgitated talking points
one of the things that I've found is
sort of a gap between young
conservatives and older conservatives is
on the issue of president Trump's okay
it seems like a lot of older
conservatives are very you know very
much believers in everything that
President Trump does they've decided in
many cases that his foibles and his
personality quirks to say the least that
those are secondary to his promulgation
of policy and they don't seem to
understand the president Trump is deeply
unpopular among young people how do you
how do you use great president from so
far and and how what's the best way to
talk about President Trump to young
people I like President Trump a lot and
I'm not gonna try to make excuses for
everything he's ever tweeted I would
hate that job I mean I don't know how
that people express I'll just do it that
was good thinking about it just gives me
anxiety but I think he's done a very
good job in terms of what he's promised
and things that haven't been delivered
upon like health care reform and the
wall for example I don't see as
exclusively his fault so overall I'm a
big step
and I think when it comes to trying to
talk about him to young people it's
about trying to strike a balance between
our a do you want someone who has all of
the like ideals that we wish Trump had
but is ineffective and gets nothing done
policy wise or do you want someone who
for all of his faults is doing more to
progress a conservative agenda in
government than anyone has in a long
time and it's not a perfect choice it's
not the best choice that I you know I
wish people had but it is ultimately the
situation that we're in and I think when
we're talking to young conservatives I
found that they like President Trump
because he's not afraid to tackle things
like the mainstream media I mean I'm not
saying he does it with the most nuance
intact but he's at least not afraid to
talk about it he's not afraid to talk
about things like trade deals or
instances where the u.s. is maybe I'm
not sure taken and being taken advantage
of is the right term but maybe not
having a fair deal and ultimately I
think young people do appreciate that
he's willing to engage in in meme
culture you know the the wall is coming
me you know that was very very popular
for folks who don't understand maybe you
can sort of explain to people what
exactly meme culture is I know there's a
subsection of the audience that knows
but maybe you can sort of define this
because this is a very millennial thing
yeah okay so memes are kind of an inside
joke that everybody is in on and we see
like leading up to 2016 that means we're
a large part of how Millennials were
engaging in the political conversation
you know they're taking things that
different candidates have said and
making it into a joke and you know to a
lot of people who are like no we need to
focus on policy about a lot that may
seem immature and childish which I'm not
saying that it's not but it's a way that
people are able to I don't know feel
more a part of the conversation and to
engage and to make it into almost almost
like a joke or something fun that people
get interested in so it's not exactly
the highest form of political
participation but it is something and so
like for young people and I think Trump
understands this like we're very into
whatever's on social media so politics
if it wants to survive and specific
candidates as well then they need to be
willing to engage in that social media
presence which Trump is for better or
worse we also see candidates like AOC
having a lot of success they're bado as
well and actually Dan Crenshaw is one of
the few comes
is I think that really gets the you know
how important it is to have a presence
on places like Twitter so can you
explain I think for folks you've talked
about a o C's popularity and the fact
that she's quite popular and you know I
get the feeling you're irritated by it
the same way that I am but what exactly
do you think it is that makes her
popular for example what what
differentiates her from the typical
politician well I mean she's younger
obviously she checks all the right
demographic you know she is she she's
not white she's a woman she's a
millennial so that all looks good for
them but also I mean for all of her
faults which she obviously has a lot of
them in terms of just knowledge of how
the economics work she is at least
addressing issues that matter to
Millennials and I think you know policy
wise Republicans can talk about things
like you know business regulations and
income tax breaks and that's great and
for a large part of the population
that's gonna resonate with them but when
you're talking about Millennials
specifically it's like look most
Millennials or at least a good amount of
them probably not paying income tax to
begin with most of them not small
business owners so that doesn't affect
them what does affect them things like
health care and you know college debt
and they care about the environment for
better or worse
AOC is talking about those issues which
Republicans by and large are not and
she's not only she's talking about them
but she's doing that on instagram live
which Millennials love so it's it's kind
of natural that people are flocking to
her so let's talk about climate change
for a second because obviously this has
been a very popular point of view for
her at least among young people not so
popular among anyone else continuin got
zero votes in the Senate I and her poll
numbers by the way you know for all of
her popularity among a subset her poll
numbers would basically tanked her polls
number if she's well below 50% in sort
of popularity polling she has high name
recognition people are beginning I think
to grow irritated with her but there's
been a lot of talk in the Democratic
Party about climate change how do you
think conservatives ought to talk about
climate change because it seems like
particularly older conservatives are
simply denying that it's taking place
the or they suggest that the science is
so deeply flawed that there's no way to
know and then there's sort of another
wing and I count myself among this wing
of folks who say that climate change
anthropogenic climate change is taking
place but those kinds of solutions that
are being posed by the left are not only
are not only foolish they're
counterproductive what do you think is
the best way to talk about the the
climate change issue with young people
well I'm definitely one of
those people who loves the environment I
don't like pollution I would like to
consider myself a conservationist and I
think the issue with the environment
right now is that the issue with climate
change isn't I mean in my opinion
whether or not the climate is gonna
change in such a way that we're all dead
in 12 years which I really don't think
it is but even without that pollution is
still not a good thing so I think we
need to be focused more on pollution
which we have you know effects or sorry
we have evidence about what the short
term terms effects are to the
environment rather than trying to
predict what may or may not happen in 10
15 whatever years because I'm like you I
do believe that mankind is contributing
to climate change but I think what we've
seen time and time again are that the
predictive models they've tried to try
to graph have not been accurate that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't care
about the environment though and I think
what Republicans and conservatives
should try to do is put forth solutions
or methods of trying to address
pollution that are not just full-on
socialism or communism let's implement
ubi and get rid of all the planes which
is what you know aoc is trying to do so
I think things like solar there's been a
lot of developments in solar energy in
the private sector that make it very
appealing for individuals just to
because of you know their own interests
or their own budget installing their own
own homes
I think conservatives should be trying
to encourage people in you know
free-market private enterprise types of
ways to do what they can as individuals
to come at climate change because
otherwise you know if the Democrats are
the only people talking about it then I
think a lot of especially young people
are gonna think that if you want to do
something anything for the planet then
you have to vote for them because
Republicans don't care which I don't
think it's true there are a lot of
Republicans who do care about the planet
so the second I'm gonna ask you because
you are both a biological woman and
identify as a woman I think you're
making some assumptions there sir
okay well that's awkward that but I'm
gonna ask you about some women's issues
in just a second but first can you
believe it's already April time has a
habit of getting away but if you have a
mortgage or kids or anyone depending on
your income you're gonna have to spend
some of that precious time getting life
insurance if you need life insurance but
you don't want to spend a lot of time
comparing it you should give policy
genius a try policy genius is the easy
way to buy life insurance online in just
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will
all the paperwork and the red tape no
Commission's no hidden fees just more
time saved for you and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also make it easy to find the right
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance the your one-stop shop for
financial protection so if you need life
insurance but you're short on time head
on over to policy genius calm and
comparequotes policy genius is easy it
saves you money and not to belabor the
point but it is fast policy genius spend
less time comparing life insurance spend
more time doing literally anything else
policy genius go check it out right now
that's policy genius.com it is going to
allow you to get that life insurance or
home insurance or any other insurance
you want policy genius the best way to
get life insurance alrighty so let's
talk about the fact that you are a woman
and as a woman this means that you have
great insight into a wide variety of
issues which I apparently cannot speak I
have been told by many so let's talk
about the fact that women in the West
have it better than any women in the
history of humanity and yet polls seem
to show that women are becoming less and
less happy over time why do you think
that is happening I think it's because
feminism has been a narrative that tells
women that they're oppressed and that
men are the oppressors and that the only
way for them to gain independence and
freedom and liberation and I think
they're for happiness is to kind of
break free from all of the institutions
that have ironically ensured that the
West has become such a great place
things like marriage and motherhood and
it's actually pretty depressing to me to
look at that because I I have placed so
much value on femininity and womanhood
and any anything that goes with that
that it hurts me on a personal level to
see feminism just so keen to I guess
disparage and dismiss what traditionally
has made women kind of the moral
gatekeepers of societies in a lot of
ways I mean it is truly puzzling to me
and I'm married obviously I have a
couple of kids and my wife who is a
doctor also yeah she also spends a fair
bit of time at home with the kids and as
soon as she's done with her residency
it'll be a wildly increased amount of
time at home with the kids and that's
what she wants to do I'm always puzzled
by the feminist argument the women are
happy or if they're not married and they
don't have kids I've I've yet to see
evidence of this proposal at work no
there really isn't any and what's so
scary I think to think of it
that among my mom is special among my
mom's friends especially she does know a
lot of women who she's been working with
and throughout their 20s and 30s early
30s rather they were happy to dedicate
their entire lives to their career they
were saying yeah I don't need kids I
don't need a husband happy just myself
but the thing with women is that when it
comes to childbearing unlike men we do
have a little bit of a you know like an
expiration date where we need to get
going on things if we want children to
happen unfortunately for a lot of women
once they're at the point in their lives
where they realize wait motherhood is
something that I want a family is
something that I want for a lot of these
women by the time that they actually try
to find a husband and settle down and
all that it's maybe too late for them to
have children so that's what I think is
so dangerous about feminism is because
they're feeding women this lie that they
don't need marriage or a husband and by
the time a lot of these women realize
it's not true it's gonna be too late for
them and I think a lot of women don't
realize that you know pregnancy after 35
it's I'm not saying it doesn't happen or
it can't happen but it is medically a
lot harder and more complicated than
when you're younger so I want to ask you
just I'm gonna throw out a couple of
terms I don't get your reaction to them
because these are becoming very
hot-button issues in our society so the
first term is rape culture and this is
something that you hear about a lot on
college campuses people suggesting that
we live in a rape culture Democratic
candidates for president suggesting that
rape culture is predominant what do you
think of that phrase and where do you
think we stand on all of this well I
think rape culture is conceptually a
real thing I think it's it's possible to
have a culture that either is condoning
of or complicit in rape I don't think
that's Western culture though I mean if
I were to think of what rape culture is
a honestly Shriya law seems a lot more
close to that where women can actually
be punished for being sexually assaulted
which is obviously not what Western laws
is about but you know it's funny to me
for all of the complaining that feminism
does about how raping misogynistic
Western culture is if we actually look
at Hollywood culture or you know hip-hop
or rap culture that's where women are
being objectified right it's not the
Christian conservatives who are
objectifying women it's I mean watch any
rap video and you're going to see a
or objectification than something that
happens on like the christian news
network or whatever so that that to me
is a huge huge double standard I mean
these feminists they're happy to
complain about people like Mike Pence
but then they'll have you know all these
hip-hop artist people like jay-z
campaigning for Hillary Clinton as if
there's some great you know respecters
of women which is absolutely not true so
I mean I don't I don't think the the
progressive movement the feminist
movement actually cares about respecting
women
I think they care about being anti
religious conservatives whenever
convenient I if I were to choose a place
where I would feel most uncomfortable as
a woman alone it would probably be the
streets of I don't know any any liberal
part of California rather than you know
a suburban place where people are buying
large conservative I mean this is one of
the things that has always puzzled me
about the left's claim to be great
defenders of women the same people who
are against concealed carry which seems
to me the only way that women in many
cases can even the odds against men or
it's argued them and the left will
similarly suggest that women should
simply ignore realities of life so if
you are in a riskier situation where you
put yourself in a riskier situation you
are therefore more at risk that is not
to justify the activity of evil men but
if I'm to walk in a high crime area
waving my wallet around that would not
be a wise move even if the person who
robbed me is morally responsible for
that if you say the same thing about
getting drunk at a bar and going home
with a guy then this is considered
sexist in some way and frankly I don't
understand the argument or how this
protects women no it doesn't at all and
I think the mistake that they're making
is that these and they really do act
like this that men who are rapists just
don't know that they're rapists right
that's why they have all these courses
on college campuses that don't rape
courses as if you could take like a an
eighteen year old male who for some
reason thinks it's okay to rape and just
tell him oh by the way it's not he would
be like oh I didn't know well then there
goes my evening plans like oh right this
is this is a problem that goes deeper
than that
so I mean telling a woman that she
shouldn't need to defend herself because
we'll just tell men not to rape is like
saying oh well there's no point in
locking your doors because people
shouldn't be robbing you obviously
people shouldn't be robbing you but that
doesn't mean that you don't try to
protect yourself and this unwillingness
on the part of the left to take I mean
to be proactive in terms of protecting
themselves I think is also why the
so misguided on issues like the border
and border security
they really do live in a lot of ways in
this fantasy utopia where everyone is
good and if you just tell people hey
stop that
then they'll listen and everything will
be fine I mean that kind of expansion of
callout culture I feel is sort of behind
what's going on with for example Joe
Biden there's been no actual allegation
that Joe Biden sexually assaulted or
even harassed anybody and yet Joe Biden
is now being treated as apparently a
sexual leper by a certain wing of the
Democratic Party it's kind of ironic to
watch some Democrats come and defend
that after they did the same thing to
Brett Kavanaugh but what do you make of
the Joe Biden allegations how seriously
should we take allegations that he was
handsy with women and putting smelling
their hair and stuff like that well I
think it's not just allegations that he
was smelling their hair like we have
like kind of footage where he was being
weird is it enough to say that he was
sexually molesting them I don't think so
I think we've known for a while that
he's kind of like your creepy uncle who
like is like touches your hair and is
weird that doesn't necessarily mean he's
a rapist I don't think we've we've seen
enough evidence to suggest that but I
think what's happening is that it's not
that all of a sudden after all of his
years in the spotlight people are just
like morally indignant about him
touching women the way he is I think
what's happening is that he's pulling
very well in terms of the other like
presidential hopeful candidates and he
does not
I guess fit what they're trying to go
for in terms of the oppression hierarchy
right because I think right now the the
top contenders are people like Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders who are obviously
white male and old so I think right now
what we're seeing is that they're
they're willing to take shots at their
own team if it means getting someone
more intersectional to the top someone
like Kamala Harris or Cory Booker
someone give me another phrase here
believe all women so we've heard this
one a lot and as a as a woman yeah maybe
you could speak to whether we should
believe all women under what
circumstances we should believe all
women well what exactly should that
phrase mean what does it mean well I
think the thing with being a woman is
that ovaries are not magical
truth-telling orbs that prevent us from
lying
that is not how that works and I think a
lot of the where that believe all women
type of thing stems from is that if
someone comes to you and they claim that
they're a survivor of rape or assault
you want to provide them with like
comfort and care and it said
etc don't say that they're asking for it
or whatever which I of course is true if
someone were personally to come to me
and say that something terrible had
happened to them I would want to comfort
them and on a personal level be there
there for them offer them assistance
whatever they needed but when we're
talking about a court of law and not
just believing someone's own personal
experience that's something about it
happened to them but then taking that
allegation and saying that someone is
guilty of assaulting another person
that's a different story
and I think when we look at what
happened with the whole Brett Kavanaugh
thing no a woman's statement is not
enough to completely ruin a man's career
or life because the thing with Western
culture is that we take rape seriously
being called a rapist is one of the
worst things that someone could be I
think you'd agree right like that's
that's awful and it's because we take
such a strong stance against rape that
we need to be very very careful with
believing statements that are they don't
have any backing now I think when I say
stuff like that I always get the issue
like okay what about the Weinsteins of
the world or you know the who was the
comedian he was recently convicted I
think well louis c.k was was gonna be
ousted i know the one from the 80s yeah
yeah Cosby yeah I can tell you're young
yeah cause what about people like that
you know I mean is it's the kind of
thing that's like any crime don't
believe any gossip you hear but if
there's actually like substantiated
accounts that go back for a while and
individual witnesses that are able to
corroborate them that's one thing but
what we're seeing is that especially in
the age of social media a single tweet
or Facebook posts is enough to ruin
people's lives and I think we really
need to scale back the witch-hunt
mentality that we have because people
are people are getting hurt and I think
what some people have suggested and I
would support is if people are filing
police reports that end up being proven
to be false there definitely needs to be
some sort of penalty for that
okay so what's here's another term for
you and you've been very critical of
this one hookup culture so we've moved
away from a relationship based culture
and toward more sexual freedom you're
very critical of hookup culture why I'm
critical of hookup culture because I'm
Pro woman and I think ultimately hookup
culture is not good for women and I'm
not saying that any
woman who goes out and sleeps with
someone you know has been victimized and
or that her life is ruined or anything
like that no but I think that women are
not the same as men it's it's obvious we
know this scientifically sex does not
have the same meaning for men by and
large as it does for women and you know
trying to teach women that they can go
out and have sex with an unending number
of men and it's not going to affect them
emotionally or psychologically not true
we've seen studies that promise beauty
has lasting effects on both genders but
especially women it can lead to things
like a depression low self-esteem and
things like that and actually they've
done studies where they look at the
total number of sexual partners women
have had before marriage and it does
affect her likelihood of getting
divorced so I mean I I get called a
fruit and stuff and it's that's not what
this is about but I think if we if we
want women to be making informed
decisions with their own lives which I
would have thought feminism should be
about then we need to be realistic about
what hookup culture does mean I mean not
to mention the fact that with STDs and
things and actually if you want women to
be protected from things like sexual
abuse and harassment I think part of
that is not putting yourself in
dangerous positions so it's so weird
like we live in an era where it's it's
seen it's deemed too personal to call
people on the phone versus texting yet
going into a club and sleeping with a
stranger is totally fine it's like we
kind of need to re-evaluate where our
moral compass I mean this is always been
puzzling to me when you watch TV now
there's a vast difference between how
sex is treated it used to be that the
way that things typically went in the
movies was a fall in love with somebody
you marry them and then there's a cut to
the curtains right yeah and now the way
that it works is that people hop in the
sack with each other and then there's
this awkward moment in every sitcom or
after they've slept together one of them
turns to them and says I love you and
that's the real that's I think that's
where one's like oh no you said I look
well that's just wow that's too intimate
yeah yeah just had sex with a person and
I think the thing with hookup culture is
that I'm actually i-i've had feminists
kind of like smirk at this but I
actually I really hate when men behave
gross toward women I I hate lewd
behavior I hate it like I will leave a
situation if that's happening and I
think what frustrates me about hookup
culture is that a lot of guys are being
rewarded that way because it does work
on some women which makes it just
unpleasant for the rest of us so I would
like and again
people are gonna be like oh you're such
a prude but I would like sex to mean
something in our culture and especially
you know I'm pro-life and I think part
of the pro-life argument shouldn't
involve the fact that unplanned
pregnancies are happening way too often
and they shouldn't be happening as often
as they are and they've actually done
studies and you know women who encounter
unplanned pregnancies who are married in
serious relationships they're a lot less
likely to even seek out that abortion
because you know they they have
stability there with a partner that they
can depend on so you know for those
reasons for for family for women for
children I just think that we really
need to rein back the crazy like pro sex
x+ whatever they're calling it
roller-coaster we've been on also worth
noting they just for the record social
science statistics tend to show that
women and committed relationships have
more and better sex than women who are
not in committed relationships because
women are actually seeking emotional
intimacy and comfort as opposed to men
who tend to seek variety for
evolutionary reasons so let's talk a
little bit about dating so you are now
engaged so let's have some advice for
young women who are looking to get
engaged we're looking to get married
what exactly should they be looking for
in a guy be with the guy that wants the
same things that you want I think a lot
of guys out there a lot of women out
there too unfortunately they're not
looking for things like marriage or
children or whatever
I've been called too picky for saying
this but it's absolutely true if you are
committed to getting married and having
kids then you need to be looking for
someone who wants the same things that
you do so you know there are a lot of
great people out there and there are a
lot of guys you might need and date and
have fun with but at the end of the day
if he's not interested in marriage and
children then don't think that you can
change him into being whoever you want
so definitely prioritize someone who
wants the same things that you do in
life it seems to me that for a lot of
young women who I see who aren't happy
this is true for young men too but it's
it's certainly true for young women then
a lot of the unhappiness Springs from a
certain war with reality that men are
not what they want men to be what do you
think it is that women don't generally
understand about men like if you had to
sum up men as a as a half of the species
in a few sentences what do you think it
is then that men are what what what do
men want I think men ultimately and this
is probably not true for a good number
of men who like women be been influenced
by third wave feminism but men tradish
we have wanted to be protectors and
providers for their families so I think
ultimately a lot of women my age we look
at men and we might see that kind of
behavior as I don't know belittling or
benevolently sexist or things like that
which is too bad because I think
relationships work best when people
aren't the same but rather when they
complement each other so I think with
men women kind of need to be a little
bit more aware that he's not just gonna
be like one of your girlfriend's he's
gonna be different and that's okay and
you shouldn't be trying to make him into
one of your girlfriends or make him as
feminine as possible relationships work
best when you when you kind of you
accept the other person and doesn't mean
you're gonna think they're perfect in
any way but don't try to fundamentally
change the the personality or beliefs of
your partner because that's just not
going to work what do you think it is
that young men don't understand about
women because obviously we are seeing
people getting married later and later
that's having some pretty terrible
consequences for the society less
responsibility taking but what do men
not get about women if you could if you
could tell guys out there what what to
expect from women what what exactly
would you be telling this is a really
hard question because I look at modern
women and I feel like I don't understand
them and I forget who said this quote
but what is it the only people who
understand women are other women and
they hate them so I don't really know
what what to say to that but I think for
men if you can find a woman who was
who's got similar values as you then I
think something that I know I my I'm
really happy my fiance understands about
me is that we are not gonna have the
same hmm like we're not gonna have the
same I guess outlook as you guys do when
it comes to things like money and career
and that's okay right because I noticed
even a guy'll I'll have people in
interviews ask me like where do you want
to be in like five years or 10 years and
honestly all of my plans long-term
revolve around family and relationships
and you know for a while I would feel
really bad about that but it's like well
that's you know I'm I'm a young woman
who wants to get married and have kids
and I don't think there's anything wrong
with that and I think men nowadays a lot
of men do find that kind of strange but
it's I mean historically it's really far
for the course
yeah well more
the things that I've found also when it
comes to relationships and this actually
is a great observation by Andrew Clavin
another one of the hosts over here is
that when people are dating there's this
constant refrain I can't find mrs. right
I can't find mr. right and he's always
saying well if you're looking for Miss
right maybe you're not mr. right maybe
you need to make yourself better in some
way how do you think that men should
train themselves to be more attractive
to women how do you think they should
train themselves to be more masculine oh
I've done videos about this and I've
made a lot of people really angry cuz
like I've done I've done dating videos
and any time I do I get like a lot of
like really angry for lack of a better
word I mean the even stuff about in
cells are picked FeO who say I have no
right to be giving advice to anybody on
this because I am a female and you know
young and I look a certain way so
therefore I should but anyway you've
asked me so I feel like me I'm blaming
you
the insults can attack me yes they do
anyways I think ultimately women and
studies have shown this are attracted to
things like confidence and success and
if you're a guy who is looking for a
girlfriend honestly the best thing that
you can do is be comfortable and assured
with yourself like don't don't I guess
put on fake confidence but become the
type of person where you have actual
traits and accomplishments that you can
genuinely be confident about so that
goes for Lino school even personal
achievement be someone who is like happy
and a beat who provides and is a benefit
to your friends and family that's
something that I think any girl is is
gonna be attracted to and on the other
side what do you what's your advice for
young women who are looking for somebody
how to improve themselves that they're
more attractive to men if they're
interested in getting married you know
what's funny I have a lot of male
viewers anytime I talk about dating I am
shocked
and made so sad by the number of them
who say that what they really want is a
girl to settle down with to have kids
with but so many females that they're
around have really bought into the whole
third wave feminism thing so they're not
looking for families or a serious
relationship even or children so I think
if you are a girl who's interested in
that don't don't be afraid of talking
about it I know it's like this taboo now
where you're not supposed to like even
mention the word marriage early on in a
relationship and I'm not saying that
get married on the first date but you
like don't be afraid of people knowing
that yeah you want to get married you're
dating with purpose cuz if the some guys
might be scared off by that but the
right type of guy will see that as a
positive so it's great it's kind of like
a self-fulfilling thing you're gonna get
rid of all the the people who aren't
interested in the same things that you
are yeah well I totally agree at this in
fact I will say you should talk marriage
on the first date because otherwise
there's no reason to be dating in the
first place well I'm frankly confused by
people who date for fun and like I
understand if you're just looking for
sex okay I get it but if you are dating
for fun I'm not sure what's fun about
dating no I hate getting super nervous
my palms are sweaty it's it's really bad
I hate it and it's the same thing when
my fiance and I started dating you know
we didn't get engaged really soon it's
not like we were rushing things but yeah
I'm the other first few dates how many
kids do you want okay that's cool do you
plan on keeping your own last name no
good you know that kind of thing so at
least we can see that we're on the same
page before it's worth going further
because otherwise I feel really bad for
for these women who kind of spend five
years in a relationship and then like oh
yeah he didn't actually want to get
married and it's like dating is not
supposed to be comfortable yeah eating
is supposed to be uncomfortable because
it is in fact a testing process of the
other person to determine whether this
is someone you want to spend the rest of
your life with and if you're too
comfortable dating then I would suggest
either you don't have enough stake in
the person you are dating because you
don't want to marry them or you're not
dating taking dating itself seriously
seriously enough I remember I didn't
date my wife for very long we've not
married for almost 11 years she was 20
at the time I was 23 when we first met
and we dated for three and a half months
before we were engaged and I was ready
to get married two and a half months and
I remember and and she knew that and so
she held off on saying I love you to me
because she knew as soon as she said I
love you I was gonna say okay so let's
get married
and remember when that finally happened
when I said let's get married she said
why can't we just enjoy this time and I
said I'm not enjoying this time this
time is terrible like let's get married
then let's then then that's when the fun
happens and that happens to be true
there's this myth that I think it's been
created by unhappy married people in
some cases about the wonders of single
life and I failed to see the wonders of
single life I was single it sucked being
married is much better yeah and I think
part of the reason why people are kind
of delaying marriage or even not getting
married at all is because marriage used
to be it used to mean something right
I'm excited to get married because I
want to live with my husband slash
fiancee I
that's gonna be fun I want to be able to
have kids but nowadays I mean people are
living together without being married
people are having kids without being
married so from that standpoint they're
like well why bother to get married and
it's like well because there is still
something special to marriage and I get
a lot of you know people who are
cohabiting that get mad at me when I say
that but if you look at the you know the
abuse rates of cohabiting couples and
not just that but the I guess like rates
of staying together of cohabiting
couples it is not a synonym for marriage
at all there is a difference let's right
mean once you've actually put some skin
in the game which is what marriage is
that's a very different thing happening
is still leaving the window open in case
you feel like lining out and from from
my generalized perspective not true for
every specific true in general so let's
talk about your religious background
because you used to be an atheist now
you're a religious person so what's your
religious background um so I grew up in
sort of like a Christmas Easter Catholic
household I mean I would have said that
I was Catholic I I went to Bible studies
when when I was a kid I drew like crayon
Jesus's I have memories of that but
ultimately like I can never remember
like really having any deep religious
thoughts or spiritual thoughts and that
was kind of me younger than growing up I
when I was 13 I remember I started this
like angsty atheist phase I was reading
I creature Dawkins and I just thought I
knew better than everybody like yeah all
of these religious scholars from like
thousands of years ago they don't know
what I know okay I'm a 13 year old
atheist so pretty big deal so that was
me and I really thought that I knew
better than everybody and I was quite
obnoxious during those years but as I
got older I started to be interested in
philosophy a little bit more so I
started reading people like Plato and
Aristotle and it's funny I actually
became sort of a deist before I circled
back to Christianity and at all but you
know theories like the theory of the
cave unmoved mover it made me start
questioning things and it's not you know
there's this belief that if you're
religious you're anti science I'm not
anti science but I think ultimately
science is the how but not the why we
can believe in the Big Bang Theory but
still think okay well then what was the
catalyst for that then what was before
that right because ultimately science is
not it's not a system that can explain
to us anything qualitative or explain
why so I started
a little bit more open to the idea of a
Creator God and then as I got a little
bit older still I started exploring
things like you know st. Aquinas and I
got more interested in the Bible and
what's interesting about Christianity is
that if you believe in the ultimate good
like the theory of forms which I which
is a big big part of my like
philosophical belief even now you you
can't help but recognize that human
beings or the world around us we fall
short in so many ways of attaining that
perfect that ultimate good Christianity
really am this the backbone of I think
all Abrahamic religions they recognize
that Fault and they try to find a
solution to it like why are humans
falling short what can we do to become
perfect because I think I mean
ultimately the trouble that I think a
lot of atheists have is that they
recognize that we we aren't perfect that
society isn't perfect but they don't
have an answer for it right oftentimes
the answer is okay well maybe more
government that will make us perfect or
you know maybe maybe this medicine this
drug then it will be perfect they
they're trying to find all of these
solutions but I think ultimately
Christianity for me is the only only
philosophy or theology where I can say
that makes the most sense and so that
when I was a 16 or 17 I became a
born-again Christian and I think since
then it's been you know you always try
to grow in your faith but it's it's you
know it's a struggle you go back you go
forward sometimes and I for the most
part of my channel I I never really
talked about being a Christian and I I
only really started talking about it
fairly recently because I realized that
there are so many people out there and
this this is kind of depressing who have
such a negative view of religion or
religious people and the the United
States the West in general is still
majority of people profess some sort of
religious affiliation but if you were to
I guess judge things based off of
YouTube or Twitter comments you wouldn't
know that you would think we're you know
they're their minority and that
everyone's an atheist so for me talking
about things like religion spirituality
or faith it's it's a way to try and at
least this is gonna sound weird but
normalize it because there are so many
young people Millennials especially who
have had no exposure to any type of
religion so they're very much of the
belief that religion is bad religion
makes you stupid if you're religious
that's because you've never opened a
science book like evolution exists
checkmate
see
is that kind of thing so that's what I'm
trying to push back on I really like
that you talk about your faith as well
because no one can call you stupid right
I mean people you call your own but they
can't call you stupid well they try
anyway I appreciate that so you're
obviously you know self educated in a
lot of ways and it sounds like you did a
lot of reading on your own what would be
your reading list for somebody who's
looking to become educated about
politics or philosophy ooh that's a hard
one so I think if it comes to something
like philosophy then I would recommend
reading the Republic so that my moniker
for my channel used to be like
philosopher king because I was kind of
like a joke but actually if you read the
Republic it's quite almost like
totalitarian in nature so I wouldn't
advocate that but I think like the the
Platonic idea of like happiness and
justice is something that I find really
interesting and if we look about how do
we achieve happiness which is what our
culture is struggling to do in so many
ways we've gone down the route I think
of hedonism and nihilism but if you look
at the ancient Greek philosophy about
how we can achieve justice or meaning or
purpose it's by fulfilling our rules and
so in my own personal life that's that's
what I find has given me the most
meaning right I look at all of my roles
and I I asked myself how I can fulfill
those better you know my role as a
fiance my role as a daughter my role as
a Christian as a show host and to me
that that is something that I can find
meaning in so there there's that and I
think let's see 1984 is there is a
really good one that I think is pretty
topical that it's funny when I was
reading that in high school I thought
like okay well this is stupid I don't
see the point but I think it's becoming
more and more relevant let's see Hannah
Arendt on totalitarianism is also
another one that I would recommend that
I think is kind of especially relevant
today because it you talked about the
the issue of atomization that I think
we're undergoing right now in society
people are becoming cut off from their
families their communities their
cultures and when you do that the only
meaningful connection you have left is
toward the state and I think that's the
problem that a lot of Millennials have
they're not really engaged in their real
life the only the only meaningful sense
of loyalty they have is maybe to some
some unseen government or state benefit
program and I think that can lead us
down a pretty dark path so let's talk
about culture because you're obviously
engaged with the
I'm just gonna ask about some of the
stuff that's out there right now you're
apparently like an award-winning Game of
Thrones quiz champion yeah according to
quiz up I am yeah that's that's quite
the word I get a little banner on my
quiz a pepper well you know you're
number one in Utah yeah it was pretty
big deal
you're the only person in Utah who
watches Game of Thrones there's like
several other people I feel okay okay so
where is it going this season and how
are you feeling about the last season
okay I really didn't like the last
season I think there are huge pacing
issues
I mean season one it felt like it went
on too long but then by the last seasons
like people are going back and forth
between Westeros and Essos and like what
single episode it didn't make sense
that's because the showrunner is like
there weren't into it they want to get
on to new project but that's that's the
whole thing so ultimately I think John
and Danny are gonna get together and
have a baby there were some major
heavy-handed foreshadowing that she's
not actually barren so I think that's
gonna happen
I'm still hoping that Daenerys is gonna
go like Evil Queen rout like the Mad
King and need to be killed that's what
I'm hoping for cuz she's yeah I'm not a
fan I hope that Tyrion or Jon Snow ends
up on the Iron Throne but I'm not too
sure that I'm pretty sure Tyrion is
gonna have some like epic but depressing
self-sacrificing moment that might leave
Jon Snow
Arya not a total fan of couldn't really
be fussed either way and let's see what
else I I hope that Jamie finds
redemption cuz he's someone who actually
really like as a character now which is
funny because the way this show started
out was not a fan yeah he's definitely
he will find Redemption he won't let him
killing Cersei Yeah right obviously I
mean they're there for shadowing too
heavily that it's gonna be him who kills
me and do ship him and Brienne it's kind
of fun yeah I mean like yeah I guess I
don't really care about that is the
truth I like Brianna I like him I'm not
I don't really care if they're together
at all also he's definitely gonna plot
so he's gonna die yeah that is coming my
great fear is that this woman with her
public which would just suck it'll end
up being that Jon will have to recede
into the West because he's died before
and he can't actually be on the Iron
Throne and that Tyrion by the way is
terrible at everything I mean let me
just point out Tyrion is the worst
advisor in Westeros he's a garbage
adviser he was a bad adviser to Cersei
he was a bad adviser to his father he
was a bad adviser to Daenerys and now
he's a bad adviser to John like he's a
terrible adviser every way around and he
keeps saying that he says smart things
and drinks I'm only seeing the drink
I'll be frank
with you so if Tyrion ends up on the
Iron Throne after all this I will be
quite disappointed with that but you
know that there's not that much time
left so honestly my big question is how
they even filled the rest of the time
because it feels like there's climactic
battle with the White Walkers that is
could probably knock that out in an
episode and then the only thing I cared
about was all the non magical stuff
actually it's kind of ticked me off that
the show has moved into too much magical
stuff and not enough of the politicking
which I always thought was was
interesting yeah well they have the the
battle with the White Walkers needs to
happen there's also the battle with the
iron iron iron Islanders that also needs
to happen so yeah yeah no one cares
about that yeah I really it also also is
like when did Cersei everyone is doing
stupid things they got rid of all the
smart characters this is my main right
Nana she's pregnant again pregnant again
okay well that that's fine but but they
keep killing off all of these smart
characters so I was a big Tywin fan
because Tywin actually thought before he
does Stannis fan right stick before
internally turns child said I know it
was like told characters flip because he
was the only one that cared about his
daughter and also he definitely had the
best actual legal claim to the Iron
Throne so there's that we're both INTJs
yeah exactly
that's exactly right so yeah and and
finally seriously is not clever the man
and then they got rid of what's-her-face
the the old woman the the Oleanna
oh yeah yeah yeah they they got rid of
all the smart characters and they
retained all the dumb ones and so it's
gonna be dumb people doing dumb things
and yeah all sorry I feel about sense
I'm really not invested in her character
no and and by the way the way that they
took out Littlefinger at the end of last
season I was that was your trick is the
smartest guy in Westeros and you took
him out with like you were hiding in the
shadows yes that's how that called a
meeting and then he came
checkmate boom okay so now I have to ask
you about Avengers infinity war so that
is coming out in the next endgame thank
you so where is it endgame going to go
okay well we know from whose contracts
have been renewed and who who's hasn't
well they already announced another
spider-man movie so shocker
Black Panther I mean yeah he's gonna
come back Chris Evans Iron Man I don't
think they're gonna make it
The Hulk I've not been thrilled with the
storyline either way lately so I
couldn't care less I'm in
mostly to see how big a role that
Captain Marvel is gonna play because
this is maybe like tinfoil hat
conspiracy stuff but I the rumors have
it that Marvel actually ended up filming
two different versions of the movie
depending on how her movie was received
that would kind of dictate how big a
role that she has I don't know if that's
true but that's just what people on the
reddit have been saying so that movie
ended up doing pretty well despite that
easy it have you seen it I did see it
okay angry that I saw it but I did see
it it's okay it is okay like it's not
the worst thing ever and it's not some
sort of like long intersectional
feminists Oh - how awful straight white
men are I mean it's it's not
none of that girl power messaging but
it's it's okay mm I I think I saw it
because I really wanted to understand
endgame I think ultimately you can watch
endgame without having seen and you're
probably gonna be fine okay good cuz
that sort of my plan yeah so that's a I
didn't see any driving force behind
seeing Captain Marvel other than people
would want me to review it and then now
I really don't want to because when
people want me to review things it makes
me not want to review those things okay
so with all of this culture talk
how do conservatives get involved in the
culture because you know it's it's easy
to get us into the political sphere we
sort of naturally exist there that's
easy to go since or the religious sphere
obviously we exist there as well how do
conservatives get involved in sort of
the cultural sphere without it seeming
forced or ridiculous well I think
conservatives just need to be more
comfortable writing and producing
cultural works and what's what's kind of
frustrating is that I know for so many
so many conservatives or conservative
families like the last thing you want
your child to do is go into the
entertainment industry right as someone
with an Asian father trust me that was
like not on the table it was like dr.
different type of doctor or lawyer so I
think I understand that because as
conservatives naturally we we value
things like stability Economic Security
and things like that which is not
conducive to the entertainment industry
but at the same time I think if all of
us are too scared to produce any sorts
of artistic works ourselves then we
can't really complain that anything
Hollywood makes us super liberal because
it's like we've kind of given them that
sphere so like I think it's really cool
that you've written fiction before
Andrew Clavin of course like he did he
does fiction and stuff as well I
encourage that I think more
conservatives need to be comfortable
taking that leap
so that's one thing and then the other
thing is that if there is a you know a
movie or a series that you really like
not necessarily because it's
conservative but because it doesn't
really shove a totally left-wing bias
then support it share it because I feel
like maybe conservatives aren't as good
as people on the Left are at promoting
movies that they care about and you know
unplanned is is something that's that's
come out now that I really enjoy seeing
how conservatives have rallied around
because if if conservative movies don't
do well then it makes sense no one's
gonna keep making them and actually I
don't know have you seen a quiet place
yes yeah so that's the movie that I
really really enjoyed and even my
fiancee who is notoriously hateful of
anything Hollywood makes had to say yeah
that's a pretty good movie and it's not
even something that's explicitly
conservative and you know both of the
the actors Jim from the audio John
forces in his wife Emily Blunt you know
they're not conservative or any
conservative or anything by any means
but in that movie it portrays a father
and a wife and the father takes care of
his family and the wife I kind of
fulfills that nurturing role which isn't
inherently pro-life film it is it really
is so that's another thing where it's
like yeah that was a good movie and no
overtly liberal or feminist messages
yeah let's support that that's one area
where it seems like Millennials may be
moving in a more conservative direction
on abortion do you feel that I kind of
do because it's funny as someone who's
pro-life I'm so often told that I reject
science and I'm only pro-life because of
religion which is actually not true
because scientists on the pro-life side
there is no scientific fact that iíve
seen pro-choice people make aside from
my body my choice which is funny because
any other issue these these progressive
feminists don't really seem to be in
favor of choice and limited government
but when it comes to abortion all of a
sudden they are so science and biology
is very firmly on the side of the
pro-life people and I think you know the
more we educate people on fetal
development and things like that the
more we can kind of drive home the
pro-life side of things because I mean
frankly I don't think you even need to
bring religion into it to make a
pro-life argument you really really
don't and I'm someone who I had never
really thought of it much but I didn't
have a problem with abortion before I
started learning about biology and just
how
quickly things like the heartbeat the
the the brain system and everything
forms so that's something we need to get
better at communicating well that is one
area where unplanned really does its
heavy work I mean there's really all you
really have to watch is the one scene
where they actually show a portion and
progress in their plans because and then
that's why it earned in our rating Matt
Walsh made a great point about this he
said if they've been showing a
gallbladder surgery that's pg-13 so
obviously even the even the critics and
the censors were deciding how to exactly
to rate this thing they wanted to rated
art because they recognized there was a
moral value to what was happening on
screen so let's talk about you mentioned
briefly before sort of the censorious
nature of the the internet left you've
had to deal with some of that have you
dealt with the the left that has come
after you in particular and they've come
after you in some peculiar ways they've
suggested that because you've
interviewed some fringe figures that
somehow this makes you fringe how do you
determine who it is that you are willing
to give a platform or interview yourself
yeah well I think for me is that I'm I'm
interested in huge cultural movements
you know I I've interviewed Richard
Spencer before at a time when by the way
they don't really bring this up but
Richard Spencer had already been on CNN
an Al Jazeera before he was ever on my
platform so like let's let's make it
clear I was a youtuber with maybe a
hundred thousand subscribers so if
anyone was giving anyone a signal boost
it was not me giving him a signal boost
but I think that the thing is I'm
someone who if if someone has a huge
movement behind them I think they are
worth listening to if at least for
understanding them I would love to be
able to interview someone like Tariq
nasheed or I need a sarkeesian you know
these far-left figures the thing is that
they don't really seem very keen to
engage I know you've had a problem with
that you trying to get someone to debate
you or just be fine yeah yeah yeah
discuss even a lot of people who are on
the far left don't want that so
personally I don't think we can combat
an ideology unless we understand it and
there was I think Dinesh D'Souza he made
a video about her he did something on
the alt-right and he actually
interviewed I think Richard Spencer and
he came out that yeah Richard Spencer is
a socialist essentially he is a white
nationalist Bernie supporter and I
remember when that came out everyone was
like oh what he's not actually on the
right like what and I was like I
interviewed him like a year and
ago and we talked about the same thing
like I've known this for a long time and
I think one of the reasons why the left
especially doesn't want us understanding
the alt-right is because the alt-right
they're essentially white black lives
matter they are it's the same racial
identity anism so seeing that the
similarities that they have doesn't make
their site look very good and it
especially doesn't make them look very
good when they're trying to blame us for
creating the alt right so yeah I when
people say that kind of stuff
nine times out of ten they haven't
actually watched the interview you know
I say in that interview that I'm not a
white nationalist I don't agree with you
I don't know how much more upfront I can
be about it so I kind of just I I tune
it out because I think there are people
that want to engage with you honestly
and there are people who don't and I've
learned that if someone is just keen on
calling you a Nazi there's not really
anything you can do to move it's a badly
motivated argument you can see it now
being used in mainstream circles they
they've brought up this this ridiculous
study that suggests that because all of
us are on YouTube basically and because
there are a lot of us who are popular on
YouTube if people watch a bunch of those
videos eventually they fall down a
rabbit hole small minority of them and
that that is somehow the fault of Dave
Rubin or me or Jordan Peterson or Joe
Rogan or you and that's really an
attempt to just fringe out anybody who
is having conversations in any way even
critical conversations that need to be
had and and more importantly they don't
care about fringing out Richard Spencer
who's four injured himself out they care
about fringing out mainstream popular
figures who happen to be heterodox
because Jordan is not necessarily
conservative Joe Rogan certainly is not
conservative Dave Rubin is a classical
liberal as he likes to call himself and
yet there's this move to try and shrink
the Overton Window so that everybody who
is not a Hillary Clinton supporter or
Barack Obama supporter is outside that
Overton Window now yeah and that's
what's frustrating to me is that I mean
like with the whole Christchurch thing
everyone was going after the right wing
because it's hashtag not all Muslims but
it is hashtag all right wingers
conveniently and they they spend a lot
more time demonizing figures like you
ordering Peterson than the actual white
nationalists and that's always so so
funny to me is that I mean let's say for
some whatever we can say that you know
this Orthodox Jew is leading people
toward the outright wouldn't
that still lead you to criticize the
actual outright more and they just don't
I I don't know why that is if they find
these ideas so repugnant then shouldn't
you be actually criticizing the people
who are espousing them taking apart
white nationalist arguments not just
conservative arguments but they really
don't spend any time doing that which is
I mean you and you know Michael knows
with his video for prayer you you guys
have spent more time denouncing the
alright then they have like the actual
outright yeah it is pretty amazing in
Jordan to I mean there are number of us
who spend an enormous amount of time
fighting white nationalism but if
there's a convenient way to fight back
against people they don't like then they
will use any club at their disposal and
it really is fundamentally dishonest
okay so I do have one more question for
you and we'll get to that in just one
second but first you actually have to be
a subscriber if you want to hear Lauren
Chen's answer and I'm gonna ask her
about Canadian politics because she has
some fluency with handsome Bernie
Sanders Justin Trudeau you have to be a
daily wire subscriber to subscribe go to
daily wire comm click subscribe you can
hear the end of our conversation over
there well Lauren Chen thank you so much
for stopping by I really appreciate your
time if you want to check out Lauren
stuff then head on over to the blaze TV
where you have a show
pseudo-intellectual Lauren thanks so
much for stopping by thanks for having
me
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]